we now want to introduce some examples
of random variables and we will start
with the simplest conceivable random
variable a random variable that takes
the values of zero or one with certain
given probabilities such a random
variable is called a Bernoulli random
variable and the distribution of this
random variable is determined by this
parameter P which is a given number that
lies in the interval between 0 & 1
using PMF notation we have the
probability of 0 being equal to 1 minus
P and the probability of taking the
value of 1 equal to P if you wish to
plot this particular PMF the plot is
rather simple it consists of two bars
one at 0 and 1 at 1 this one has a
height of P and this has a height of 1
minus P Bernoulli random variables show
up whenever you are trying to model a
situation where you run a trial and that
trial can result in two alternative
outcomes either success or failure or
heads versus tails and so on another
situation where Bernoulli random
variables show up is when we're making a
connection between events and random
variables here's how this connection is
made we have our sample space Omega and
within that sample space we have a
certain event a and outside the event a
of course we have the complement of a
our random variable is defined so that
it takes a value of 1 whenever the
outcome of the experiment lies in a and
it takes a value of 0
whenever the outcome of the experiment
lies outside the event a so that it lies
in the complement this random variable
is called the indicator random variable
of the event a it is equal to 1 if and
only if event a occurs
and the PMF of that random variable can
be found as follows
this is PMF notation this is the
equivalent probabilistic notation this
is the probability that a random
variable takes a value of 1 now the
random variable takes the value of 1 if
and only if event a occurs and so what
we have is that our random variable the
indicator random variable is a Bernoulli
random variable with a parameter P equal
to the probability of the event of
interest indicator random variables are
very useful because they allow us to
translate a manipulation of events to a
manipulation of random variables and
sometimes the algebra of working with
random variables is easier than working
with events as we will see in some later
examples